oblige pas y aller tu peux continuer à
me donner des cours jetez enseigner tout
ce que je sais le sujet est clos
d'accord on en a discuté à nauseam ckoi
ad nauseam tu sais pas j'en connais une
qui doit aller à l'école
[Musique]
cécile zone qui peut me dire combien
font à +3 remet tout le monde sait que
ça fait 6 marie tu veux bien te lever
serais tu me dire combien font disons
135 x 57
très bien cet 1695 la racine carrée 87,7
et et des poussières sinon ça veut dire
quoi à 12 jan je pense que votre gaz et
surdoué
diane voulait que marie soit comme les
autres rrc vie normale une enfance une
dame qui attend devant notre porte
cette dame est à grand mère c'est un
macbook chéri qu'est ce que tu fais
c'est mon mari n'a rien armes à feu en
affirmant qu'ils le signent et loin
devant l'ex faisant partie pourquoi nos
sur yann tainguy que je dois corriger
les grandes personnes les gens n'aiment
pas les jeux c'est tout arrive
[Musique]
je lui empêche d'exploiter ce potentiel
quelle est ta plus grande peur c'est de
gâcher la vie paris
[Musique]